when we were dominating the debate on
critical race theory in late 2020 and
then really 2021 you saw the left
Retreat from these issues all of a
sudden Robin D'Angelo was nowhere to be
found ibram candy was you know on the
defensive and then you saw this shift in
the debate when those same teachers and
districts that had been pushing critical
race theory in 2021 started really
doubling down on especially trans
non-binary and queer identity formations
as the the new thing the new trend the
new
um you know current current thing with
capital c and capital T and they thought
that they could really just shift the
debate and win on these grounds and so
um in a sense they're complementary they
can play uh three-card Monty with these
two ideas but I think there's also a
deeper Nexus or connection between the
two
um you know students at the elementary
school level high school level
um uh uh you know they can be
shamed they can be told that their
racial category
um you know let's say for example white
students told that they have white
privilege white fragility unconscious
white racial superiority they're part of
the systemically racist Society by
virtue of their ancestry
but that doesn't really in some ways
help tremendously you can't change your
race they can't do anything about it
um at a at the level of their own
identity
um but these uh sexual identities offer
an escape from the guilt and shame that
was instilled on the critical race
Theory narrative and they offer an
escape so you get in some cases you know
I talk to teachers that say yeah you
know 40 of my white female students in
middle school now identify as non-binary
queer transgender Etc and so it gives
them an Avenue for participation not
just at the level of ideology but the
deeper level of identity and so in some
ways critical race Theory serves to push
people into some of these constructs as
an Avenue out
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute
and author of the brand new book
America's cultural revolution how the
radical left conquered everything Chris
Ruffo my friend welcome back to the
Reuben report
it's great to be with you
Chris did they conquer everything
everything Chris
yeah I mean obviously there's a little
bit of fun and hyperbole certainly they
haven't conquered your studio or my
studio even though they might be banging
down the door at any minute
um but in all seriousness they really
did I mean I think that's what we really
learned in 2020 all of a sudden people
looked around and they saw that all of
their institutions had been conquered by
the ideologies of the left whether it's
critical race Theory radical gender
ideology so-called diversity equity and
inclusion all of our private companies
were really riding that BLM line and so
many Americans looked around and said
well what happened how did this suddenly
occur that all of these neo-marxist
ideologies seem to be at the Forefront
of all of our institutions and the
reason I wrote this book was to answer
that question and to dig deep into the
history going back more than a half
century explaining how this happened
what is going on with our institutions
and how we can fight back all right so I
want to dive into all of that and
clearly my audience knows an awful lot
about it and has attracted you for quite
some time you've been on the show a
million times but for for somebody
that's watching this that that is not
too familiar with your work how did you
get involved in this whole thing because
you've become sort of the the center of
fighting back against this
that's right it really all started with
my investigative reporting for City
Journal magazine I looked at some
training programs in the summer of 2020
sources around the country were sending
me documents from their Dei programs
talking about systemic racism White
Privilege white fragility segregating
employees on the basis of race and
shaming some employees and praising
other employees based on their ancestry
and this reporting really exploded in
the season of 2020 and I identified that
the ideology that was driving this kind
of programming was critical race Theory
I went on Tucker when he was still on
Fox News and asked president Trump to
pass an executive to sign an executive
order abolishing CRT trainings from the
federal government he did so and that
really launched this whole line of
reporting this line of activism and
really this line of inquiry to say
um you know in a democracy we think that
majority opinions should be translated
in our public institutions that's not
the case for example when schools are
pushing CRT on kids over and against the
best wishes and the desires of parents
and so while I made my name in a certain
sense as an activist as a muckraking
reporter what I wanted to do was also
give those readers a chance to go deeper
a chance to really understand what's
happening under the surface what is the
genealogy of these ideas
um and and really go beyond the quick
hit you know headlines and news bites
and giving something very substantive so
that those of us on the right or in the
center or even the center left can be
armed with all the information that we
need in order to start fighting back
against these ideologies both at an
intellectual level but also at a
political level all right so let's do
some 101 for some of the people that are
just catching up on this stuff can you
define critical race Theory
sure critical race theory is an academic
discipline that holds that the United
States is a fundamentally and
systemically racist country and that all
of our institutions from our legal
system to our constitution even to the
Civil Rights act itself are smoke
screens that preach the values of
Liberty and freedom but in reality serve
to uphold a system of naked racial
domination and so it's this idea that
any disparity in outcomes can be traced
back to a hidden a secret or an
invisible racist system that the
critical race theorists believe they're
privileged in their ability to ferret
out all of these hidden racisms and so
um critical race Theory though is the
ideology at the tip of the spear but it
traces back decades upon decades back to
neo-marxist ideology that's really the
the very basis of this and so while
critical race theory was hotly debated
in the headlines for a number of years
we have to understand that in order to
really root it out we have to go even a
further step deeper so when we had that
like three month blip probably about a
year and a half ago where everybody in
mainstream media kept saying oh they
don't teach critical race theory in
schools they don't teach it in schools
and yet every day those of us that that
live at least partially online we would
see you know curriculum that was getting
leaked we'd see teachers you know caught
on the DL admitting they're teaching it
Etc et cetera what was that like for you
because it wasn't necessarily that they
were handing a book to the children that
said this is critical race Theory but
they were figuring out other ways to
leak the ideas that you just expressed
into all of the stuff that they've been
teaching yeah I mean it was unbelievable
because I was publishing these stories
with leaked curriculum documents I was
always posting the original Source
materials sometimes hundreds of pages of
materials and uh and then even in States
like California Washington and Illinois
they were putting critical race Theory
explicitly in their state mandated
curriculum but for months the left said
critical race Theory doesn't exist it's
a it's a it's a boogie man it's a kind
of phenomenon of a fevered right-wing
imagination and in all of these pieces
attacking me they never once addressed
the specifics of my reporting where I
put it in very clear black and white
this is what they're teaching these are
the principles of critical race Theory
this is the intention of these lessons
and so they tried to maintain that
posture for a long time the critical
race Theory doesn't exist but what
happened is that we hit them every day
with more facts more evidence more
concrete documentation so that position
slowly became untenable and even the
more honest in writers and journalists
on the left started to say well you know
critical race theory is in the
curriculum maybe it's not labeled
critical race Theory but certainly the
principles are at play here
um and so there was a kind of concession
for a little bit and then it flipped
following the really natural script that
we've seen over and over then they
started saying yeah there is critical
race Theory and good we want critical
race theory in the curriculum so you saw
even the largest teachers union in the
United States passed a resolution saying
that we want to have critical race
theory in all 14
000 local school districts
um you know they said it very explicitly
by name we love CRT we want CRT
everywhere and then the media started
defending critical race Theory
um but there was one thing that was
really interesting is that parents
throughout this whole debate throughout
this whole subterfuge and and really
manipulation on behalf of the media they
knew what was happening and that's why
they showed up at school board meetings
that's why they were protesting that's
where they were demanding changes to the
curriculum because they saw not just my
reporting but what was happening in
their local communities what kids were
bringing home in their backpacks every
day after school and they said wait a
minute we do not want racial
scapegoating in our curriculum we do not
want our kids being judged as avatars of
racial categories and we do not want to
be taught a false History of the United
States that condemns it as a racist
Society through and through and so
um you know that was the Arc of the
debate and I think ultimately whether
you look at public opinion whether you
look at legislation whether you look at
even the posture of our opponents on the
left I think we resoundingly won that
debate over the course of that year or
two-year period can you talk about how
this is connected to all of the gender
stuff so it's not just race stuff
because when you talk about the parents
I think the thing that Lit the parents
on fire they were they were pissed to a
degree about the race stuff but to me it
was the gender ideology and then the the
election of Junkin in Virginia that that
Lit that on fire and then we'll talk a
bit more about Disney and DeSantis
because you had something to do with
that as well but how the gender piece of
this is connected it oddly to the race
piece of this
yeah I mean look um if you look back 50
years at left-wing ideology once they
abandoned the Orthodox Marxist idea of
class conflicts so the two great
categories are you know the bourgeoisie
and the proletariat or the uh capitalist
class and the working class that stopped
working by the mid 20th century and
left-wing intellectuals were looking for
other soft spots other lines of attack
and they settled on race and sex or race
and gender and that was the new
formulation and so when we were
dominating the debate on critical race
theory in late 2020 and then really 2021
you saw the left Retreat from these
issues all of a sudden Robin D'Angelo
was nowhere to be found ibram candy was
you know on the defensive and then you
saw this shift in the debate when those
same teachers and districts that had
been pushing critical race theory in
2021 started really doubling down on
especially trans non-binary and queer
identity formations as the the new thing
the new trend the new
um you know current current thing with
capital c and capital T
um and they thought that they could
really just shift the debate and win on
these grounds and so
um in a sense they're complementary they
can play uh three-card Monty with these
two ideas but I think there's also a
deeper Nexus or connection between the
two
um you know
students at the elementary school level
high school level
um uh you know they can be shamed they
can be told that their racial category
um you know let's say for example white
students are told that they have white
privilege white fragility unconscious
white racial superiority they're part of
the systemically racist Society by
virtue of their ancestry
but that doesn't really in some ways
help tremendously you can't change your
race they can't do anything about it
um at a at the level of their own
identity
um but these uh sexual identities offer
an escape from the guilt and shame that
was instilled on the critical race
Theory narrative and they offer an
escape so you get in some cases you know
I talk to teachers that say yeah you
know 40 of my white female students in
middle school now identify as non-binary
queer transgender Etc and so it gives
them an Avenue for participation not
just at the level of ideology but the
deeper level of identity and so in some
ways critical race Theory serves to push
people into some of these constructs as
an Avenue out and uh I think that we're
seeing that in in many places and and in
some ways it's actually been a harder
debate debate to win I think that with
CRT we had a very successful debate and
I think that we with gender and I'd be
curious to hear your perspective and
sexuality we're still in a very kind of
amorphous situation where it's not quite
clear which side is winning it's not
quite clear quite quite clear
um both of those apply but it's not
quite queer or clear
um you know where this debate is heading
I think there's a stalemate in some
sense and uh I I'm not sure what what's
your interpretation of where we are well
I mean one of the things that you know I
had Douglas Murray on last week and that
we've talked about for quite some time
is that the L's and the G's and the B's
which are a sexuality not a sexual
identity really need to separate from
the t's I am not denying or gay people
let's say are not denying biology they
are not trying to force a young person
to alter their body in a way that is not
congruent with with reality now you
could have a personal religious belief
on
homosexuality personally I think that's
fine as long as you're not trying to
legislate legislate it but there's a
fundamental difference between sexuality
and sexual identity and that sort of
blurring of reality is the problem so as
I often say and I'm sure you've said
something similar there's no group that
is more anti-lgb than the t's and the
t's there's also no group that is more
anti-female than the teas who now want
biological men to beat women in sports
so I think the the Confluence or the
combination of those letters has been
really really dangerous for for gay
people in general
yeah I I I that's that's interesting I I
do Wonder too I think that there's
something happening on the political
right where
um you know there was a a kind of a
concession in a sense on the political
right the moral majority of the 1980s
and 1990s has really disappeared as a
political force you don't see anything
analogous to the Ralph reads or the pat
Robertsons you know the 700 Club guys
um that generation of social
Conservative Christian conservatives has
I I think really you know in some cases
that literally died off but in other
cases just kind of disappeared as a
political force there was a a period I
think where there was a kind of truce on
some of these social issues and so it's
it's been interesting to watch the
rights start to change a little bit and
I think what's really uh led to this and
I think it's a disastrous move on behalf
of the radical gender activists is to
actually say now hey we're going to come
into institutions come into schools and
then push not just you know tolerance of
of of you know of of gay sexuality so
saying hey there are gay kids in schools
they should be you know treated equally
as everyone else they shouldn't be uh
bullied shamed or humiliated because of
their sexuality they should be brought
into the wider Community I think that
virtually everyone supports uh that kind
of basic dignity intolerance but what
we're seeing now in schools is that
they're saying they're pushing it as an
ideology saying you know not not just
transgender or transsexuality which is
you know uh in its modern sense roughly
a hundred years old but they're actually
now inventing you know uh you know
genders and sexualities of you know
non-binary two-spirit all of these
Boutique identities that that in a real
sense are fake categories
um and they're pushing them
um onto kids and they're really a a
Desiring and really using kids that are
impressionable
as Pawns in a greater political game and
I think that's what people are really
revolting against they're saying hey
wait a minute you have a policy where
you can secretly transition my child
into a non-binary they them and then
push the the identity into a political
activist posture without even notifying
me as the parent is is so deeply
manipulative and I think that you know
it is I hope a miscalculation on behalf
of these activists because I just don't
think that that can stand over the long
term a lot of people on the right are
uncomfortable talking about these issues
uncomfortable uh you know activating
against them but as we've seen with all
the detransitioners we see with the the
the these horror stories
um it's untenable in in the medium term
and so I think that while the debate
might be a bit of uh in kind of a
stalemate now I think that ultimately
it's got to shift it's got to go back to
the center yeah well you're right about
what a what a damn shame it is because
for the right the the Moral Majority the
Rick santorums Mike Huckabee types they
they've moved on from these things Trump
ran first term around you know first
term as pro-gay marriage people put it
to bed and then they've just rehashed
all of this stuff and and the average
gay person really wants nothing to do
with it but you know the activist class
always needs something to do but to that
point you know as we've exited gay pride
month and thankfully we can go back to
shame Hallelujah uh you know there were
so many that that ridiculous flag that
once was the rainbow that included
everything but now they've politicized
the rainbow with this triangle and the
circle and the brown and the whole thing
the fact that they're putting that up at
the White House when you see that up at
the White House equal with the American
flag which actually might be a violation
of the Constitution or when you see that
hanging outside of the Canadian prime
minister's office I think most people
don't realize it's a political flag
people think oh it's just celebrating
sexuality but it's actually political in
nature that's really what you're saying
Yeah a hundred percent I mean it is a
political movement and it's a political
movement with its own iconography which
is shown you know kind of propaganda
messaging
um and it's and it's it and it's like
any other political movement
um it has its set of symbols and
certainly what I think of when when
Biden hung the uh the progress pride
flag I guess it's called now the one
with all the the the different shapes
um look it's a basic political patronage
move
um Biden knows where the energy is on
the activist part of his political base
um he knows that this is a a very
important part of his Coalition and he
is essentially rewarding the activists
within that Coalition with this symbolic
display and uh kind of White House
ceremony
um you know uh I I think that in a sense
it's kind of normal patronage politics
um and so that's how I view that
um and and and Biden is you know for all
of his faults and for all of of his
seeming you know kind of a slow kind of
mental capacities as he ages he knows
which way the wind is blowing he knows
where the Democratic Coalition is and I
think that it shows really the power of
that activist narrative the power of
that activist apparatus that they get
their flag hung up uh you know it where
really only kind of the American flag or
the national flag should be hanging in
my opinion and I think that the debate
about flags and symbols is really
important the things that we Elevate
symbolically are the things that we
value in a more human and meaningful way
and so we should be quite careful and
quite deliberate and have really an open
debate about what kind of symbols that
we put in places of national prominence
and certainly in a public school
um you know you couldn't hang a crucifix
at the top of the public school a
religious symbol um you know you
couldn't claim uh you couldn't hang a uh
you know partisan uh political flag at
the top of a public school classroom and
so I think that it's it's it's very
interesting that the pride and progress
pride flag are given an exemption
um for the for restrictions on religious
and political uh symbolism in classrooms
it's a it's a pretty sophisticated
um uh reason that that is the case
they've been very um very good at at
kind of laundering the political message
um that is that is that is the essence
of this
um with a kind of vague tolerant
diversity Equity inclusion surface level
messaging that allows it to be displayed
in places where
um the kind of
analogous flags of any other political
or religious movement would not be
allowed would not even really be
contemplated right well they they say
it's all about inclusivity but that flag
does not include me it doesn't include
Douglas Murray or Peter Thiel or Spencer
Clavin or the litany Rick Grinnell or
plenty of other gay people but let's
move on for a sec because one of the
other things that sort of caught fire in
the last year was the war that DeSantis
went uh at with Disney and you were a
piece of that at a couple different
fronts but am I correct you were the one
that leaked the original Disney videos
right
yeah that's right yeah I um I have a
source inside Disney actually multiple
sources inside Disney I had reported on
their critical race Theory employee
training program in 2020 and then in or
in 2021 rather and in 2022 as the Disney
fight was brewing with the santis one of
my sources leaked me these really
incredible videos from inside the
company as well as some other supporting
documents
um that that that kicked it off and even
Governor DeSantis at the bill signing
stripping Disney of its special
privileges he he said during the
ceremony he said you know if rufo hadn't
leaked these videos I don't know if we'd
even be here that was really a pivotal
moment in this fight and it's an
important fight because it not only
marks a fight about gender ideology in
schools you'll remember that that's what
this was all about the parental rights
and Education Act but it also marks a
shift on the political right
um against this libertarian corporatist
um you know let's we can call it a
neoliberal tendency on the political
right where the corporations are always
right we never we never fight with
corporations we never get crosswise with
the fortune 100. DeSantis change that
very dramatically and although I think
it you know it kind of enraged
Libertarians
um I think most conservatives are now
thinking wait a minute these companies
are not just creating products and
services you know adding to the the GDP
but they're actually waging uh
ideological fights they're wading into
uh partisan cultural fights and they're
now crosswise with conservative voters
and we need to have political leaders
that are willing to stand up not just to
our our traditional opponents on the
left but even these um these new
opponents within our traditional
Coalition that have now deviated from
support of the political right and
weighted into the culture war on behalf
of the cultural left
right so when that happened and then
DeSantis decides to use uh state power
to push back against it were you
surprised to see some of the you know
whether we want to call them neoliberals
or fake conservatives you know guys like
Mike Pence so this is too much
government power Nikki Haley too much
government power when finally a
conservative was actually doing
something about the things that they're
always complaining about
yeah I mean I wasn't surprised but I was
certainly frustrated and disappointed
because they're just repeating this
brain dead script that has been
programmed in them since the 1980s but
it's not the 1980s anymore and while
that was probably the right ideology or
philosophy or policy for the time things
have shifted a bit and even on their own
terms though I I argue that with
Libertarians all the time on this and
then sometimes they concede I say wait a
minute
even on libertarian grounds I think
DeSantis did the right thing and they
say what he interfered with a private
company what do you mean I said well
look at it Disney in in decades before
DeSantis was in office used their
economic power use their lobbying power
and use their cultural power to extract
special privileges from the state of
Florida they had special tax structure
special regulatory structure special
real estate structure you know they had
the the right to create their own
nuclear power plant uh at some point
through the through the kind of
sweetheart deals they've negotiated with
the state and these are special
privileges crony capitalist privileges
right none of their competitors and none
of the other private companies had and
in fact descending the world doesn't
have a nuke
see what zero does not have nukes
although maybe it should you know and
send them to uh the Ukraine or something
I don't know but but
um you know none of the other companies
had these privileges so in fact DeSantis
was doing nothing but level the playing
fields so that Disney had to compete
with all the others and it created
actually a more free market and a less
crony capitalist system
and of course then they turn very silent
and they say uh oh
um I can't fall back on my ideology
anymore you know irand is is somewhere
in the corner you know crying
um you know we actually have to have a
substantive debate about culture and
Libertarians are very nervous they want
to be accepted by the left on culture
um
and it but but what I think it really
shows is that on on all grounds except
for the simple friend enemy grounds uh
if you're you know on on the left I
think that that his move was defensible
on all grounds and not just defensible
on all grounds but really put the
priorities in the correct rank order it
said look protecting the the the
flourishing of our society of and of our
kids and of our families is more
important than protecting corporate
interests to me that is the fundamental
America is about the protection of life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
um and and our economy and our companies
should all be thought of as means in
order to achieve the end of human
happiness so I think DeSantis is in the
right both looking at our founding
principles looking at libertarian
principles and looking at what might be
considered social conservative
principles so as long as we're talking
about the Santa's doing some stuff right
related to this I I think one of the
other Institute institutions that's done
some stuff right lately obviously is the
Supreme Court I I take it you are pretty
happy about the reversal of this
affirmative action decision at Harvard
and if you want to talk about you know
what you're doing here in Florida that
would be fine as well but that that
basically we are removing some of this
what some might call uh structural or
systemic racism from the system
yeah that's right I think this is a huge
ruling although it's certainly not
enough I'd like to see some other
precedents such as uh Griggs versus Duke
power company uh overturned
um you know we have what is that I want
to sure it's it's it's uh it's what
really established the notion of
disparate impact so
um if if a policy or a system is neutral
it doesn't favor one racial group or
another but it creates disparate
outcomes you can read racism into that
that is could be deemed illegal
discrimination and so to say for example
that um elderly Asian uh females are are
incarcerated at a lower rate than you
know um you know young white males or
young black males or young Latino males
um you know you could read into that
saying oh that's a disparate outcome and
therefore racist we have to interrogate
it I think we have to get to on the
other hand a system of colorblind
equality
um very simple we treat you you as an
individual with with equally under the
law with due process we don't
discriminate against you on on cause of
your race or ancestry but you're
actually put into our system and you'll
be judged on your individual Merit that
is the only kind of system that can be
successful at the kind of scale that we
have with you know more than 300 million
people in our country you can't treat
people as as as as as
reflections of a racial group or as
symbols of a racial group you have to
treat people equally and so I think
we're getting there
um and we're getting there slowly the
Supreme Court is quite a bit how quite a
big help on this path but we have to
really push further I want everyone to
feel that
um that they're given a fair shot that
they're treated equally and that their
their outcomes in life are of course
dependent on where they came from their
Origins but also depended on their hard
work and fair treatment so that what
what people earn they really feel like
that they have earned it through their
own efforts they haven't been punished
or rewarded on anything else besides
their own efforts their own
contributions
what do you do you think with the people
that use every positive thing that comes
out of the system as proof of the
system's failure in other words so we
get a good decision let's say that you
and I are agreeing from the Supreme
Court on affirmative action but then if
you watch MSNBC or you watch CNN you
listen to AOC or Elizabeth Warren or
Kamala Harris or Joe Biden for all of
them it was proof that the court is
corrupted thus proof we could probably
take this back to critical race Theory
proof that the system itself is designed
against the people that seems like an
intractable problem that every time we
try to free the people more that the the
certain set of activists which now
includes people literally like the
president of the United States use that
decision to undermine the system itself
yeah I mean I think it's a it's a
dangerous game that they're playing
um they interpret every political loss
for them
um as evidence of corruption racism and
then that justifies the need to abolish
the system reform the system pack the
courts
um and so it's a circularly
self-reinforcing argument every time
they win it's evidence of the virtue of
their ideas every time they lose it's
evidence of the corruption of their
enemies and to a certain extent all
politics is like this you know certainly
many people on the political right and
many people on the political left share
in that mode of thinking it's a basic
partisan reflexive thinking
um however
we really have to in this case on the
political right we really have to shift
the debate to the substance and the
Merit one thing too that was totally
lost in the Supreme Court decision is
that they were saying oh this is
evidence of white supremacist see but
the plaintiffs in the Supreme Court case
were Asian Americans you know that was
like totally like Asians are the new
white supremacists dude come on yeah
exactly the Asian either the Asian uh
White supremacists the Chinese immigrant
white supremacists I mean you know so so
we have to really what I found most
effective in all of my debates and
narrative kind of warfare
um with the left is that the more you
can stick to the very specific concrete
tangible elements of the story the more
that you can make a persuasive case that
is substantive that sticks to reported
matter or sticks to the real concrete
narrative the more likelihood we have to
win we did it on critical race Theory I
think we're doing it slowly
um you know on on gender and I think we
can also do it on policies like
affirmative action where by the way
Americans of all racial backgrounds
white black Latino Asian
um all those the major racial groups
oppose affirmative action and so we have
to take that public sentiment we have to
reinforce it with a a political
narrative and substantive reporting and
and court cases Etc and then start to
actually say you know what we're going
to take this momentum we're going to
take all of this uh Goodwill and public
support and start to change the system
and look Republicans have been very wary
of any reforms to our civil rights uh
bureaucracy in the United States it's
time that we start pushing in that
direction we have to reform the Civil
Rights Act of 1991 which codifies
disparate impact analysis into federal
law we have to we have to move beyond
that and reform our civil rights law and
in some ways really strengthen our civil
rights law in order to ensure full
colorblind equality for everyone in our
country
uh what do you what do you uh think
about the idea that some states now will
just continue to do it right and some
states will continue to do it wrong so
as you know I very publicly left Cali
for Florida I feel like I live in a
different country here I mean the set of
values in this state are 180 different
than they were in Cali Cali is
continuing to go down that road Florida
is stopping that Tennessee let's say
Texas more in line with us New York
Connecticut Jersey going down that road
do you sense that that it will just
continue to go that way and also that's
partly because of the migration of
people where the blues are going to get
Bluer and the reds are going to get
redder it doesn't even matter I guess
yeah
yeah I I mean it appears that that is
the trend and I anticipate that the
trend will continue but I actually think
that in in a larger sense a structural
sense that that's good that's exactly
how our government was intended to be we
were intended to be a federalist system
with states that can pursue very
different visions of governance very
different sets of values that they
Orient as their kind of hierarchy of
values let's say and so in a sense uh I
like to see that California and Florida
and Idaho and and New York are pursuing
very different visions of government it
gives the citizens of every state the
ability to look at what's happening to
to judge and compare to decide what they
want and they can either fight and
Advocate within their states or they can
move to another state that's more
friendly this is actually good but
there's one big caveat States like such
as California should not be allowed to
violate federal law and should not be
allowed to violate the principles of our
Constitution and so when States like
California I recently exposed at UC
Berkeley law Dean saying that even
though affirmative action is illegal in
the state of California we do it
secretly and this is how we do it that's
that's not just the policy that
California can have or not have that's a
violation of the 14th Amendment and as a
law the law professor uh you know Dean
timarinsky should know this but we
should be cracking down at the federal
level for any kind of violation of the
Constitution while giving States the
latitude to to pursue their own Vision
in their other state policies and so
look I I live in Washington state which
has its uh its advantages and
disadvantages I spend a lot of time uh
in your neck of the woods in Florida I
see the difference I'm holding out
strong here
um but I but I certainly appreciate the
fact that states like Florida Texas
Idaho Tennessee are are pursuing a
different path and are doing some really
good things what's the school that
you're working on here in Florida is it
new school no it's Florida that's right
the new College of Florida new College
sorry yeah
yeah so new College of Florida is a
perfect example Governor DeSantis
appointed a group of Trustees including
me to take over this college to reform
it to abolish their Dei bureaucracy to
install principles of colorblind
equality to hire new faculty with
expertise in the classical liberal arts
and to give the college A Renewed
mission of pursuing the classical
liberal arts education which kind of
paradoxically is now coded as a
conservative education my life story
right there disappeared from all of our
uh institutions in the last few decades
and so
um look this is going to be a home for a
wide diversity of an opinion and we're
actively recruiting Scholars aligned
with the classical liberal Mission and
so we're hoping to announce some new
professors I think some of the people
that maybe you might be excited about
are currently in the mix for for
professorships at the new college and
we're we're going to be transforming
this institution that is not just
important for the campus itself but it's
important because it's a model for all
other Red State Governors and
legislators and citizens to say you
don't have to put up with uh you know
America's cultural revolution you don't
have to put up with all of your
institution being captured by left-wing
ideologues there is now A playbook for
retaking the institutions reforming the
institutions and reorienting the
institutions towards your values
I got one more for you rufo uh we're
posting this same week that the book is
coming out I have no doubt that it is
going to do extremely well and that it
will also be left off the New York Times
bestseller I hate to tell you that's how
it works but I wonder just in terms of
media strategy I know you're willing to
go into the lions den and go after these
guys uh are you willing to to go into
MSNBC and go to CNN and go to say the
New York Times uh board over there and
all of those things you're not going to
get the invites and they're also not
going to respond to you but just for the
record so that once uh once it's all out
there
yeah of course I am I love it um I've
not only stated publicly on Twitter that
I'm open to to interviews and stories
and and media appearances with all of my
critics but I've actually reached out my
team has reached out proactively to all
of those outlets and and and and I will
say and this is a point of optimism I
think you'll be happy about this I'm
sensing a bit of a shift I've actually
got a lot of response from people at
everywhere from Jacobin to MSNBC to the
New York Times to the New Yorker they're
starting to re-engage and so I think
you'll see
are you going to be on MSNBC to talk
about this book MSNBC is the one that
has not responded unfortunately but a
lot of the print Publications on the
left have responded they might engage
with interviews they might engage with
podcasts they might engage with reviews
of the book and so I really hope that
that the book which look I think sent a
lot of Center left audiences are going
to read this and say oh wow I'm actually
I heard that rufo is a you know
right-wing fanatic but actually his book
is totally right I agree with it I think
we might see the beginnings of a
re-engagement now that the kind of
George Floyd hysteria has started to die
down I sense that the left is maybe
willing to start coming back to the
table and start engaging in debate I
hope that the book uh launches that
accelerates that Trend I hope that not
only conservative readers uh appreciate
it but also Center and even Center left
readers appreciate it I really want it
to be a focal point for re-engaging in
this conversation at the end of the day
we're one country we all have to live
here and we'll all be much better off
that we can engage subsequently with one
another and I hope this book contributes
to that process the book is America's
Cultural Revolution and if they come for
look at you've even got a copy you truly
are a professional my friend if they
come for you in Washington you're always
welcome in the Free State of Florida
thank you good seeing you man you too if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell